I grew up here in Southern California I
grew up in a two-parent household I was
as functional as any others I guess
um right right nothing super big and
drastic you know just the normal
everyday life stuff so I moved out at 18
I went to college for a few years and
then I couldn't really decide on a major
which is something that they really
pressured me to do is decide on a major
and I couldn't so then I started working
I got a job and I was like well I'm
getting paid why do I need to go to
college maybe maybe I should have
rethought get back then but that was my
decision you know it was like already
getting paid so I just stopped going to
school
I've been important for 14 years a long
time
right I guess that's a great question
because I think that my origins into
this industry are what have given me
this longevity so I entered in 2005 and
I entered it just thinking was gonna be
a one-time thing I did my first scene
with belladonna who's a porn legend and
my late husband Carlos Betts had shot
her for a Japanese magazine and she saw
that his portfolio and she saw me in his
portfolio and she liked my look so
Carlos and I had been concurrently we
had been working on a photo project
ultimately to become a book and a book
named fat girl so we were compiling
images for that at the same time he shot
her so we thought ok we'll ask her if we
can shoot together you know some really
like sexy sexy sex implied stuff like
nothing really penetrative or real sex
so we met with her and she declined to
be in our photo book but she offered me
a scene so I thought okay [__] it I
never thought of this I got never I
don't I don't really even watch porn
but I thought you know it's gonna be
like a funny experience you know I'll
just do it I'll get paid and I'll just
have something to like you know like
have memories and when I'm old I could
be like oh ha ha I was in a porn but the
experience was great
and I I loved it and at this around that
time the circle that Carlos and I were
in they were all performers directors
all that so it was very easy for me to
transition into the career because my
friends were directing so they would
hire me for their projects and after
about a like three or four projects I
thought well this is something that is
going to be you know it's gonna be more
than just oh ha hides at a porn and so I
took a step back and I had to assess
like okay I am an exhibitionist I like
getting paid to [__] like this is really
fun I love being in front of the camera
but I needed a deeper reason for myself
to continue in this industry and
continue [__] on film and camera so I
decided that with my work and with my
body and my body of work I was going to
my goal would be to represent a fat
sexual person because media doesn't
really represent that especially back in
2005 there's a little bit more
representation now but back then you
know it was just the fad tropes you know
like fat sidekick funny person sad
person lazy person all this stuff yeah
there's a slew of people that love
everything like this standard of like a
thin you know like a blonde person with
fake boobs and ass whatever like that
does get a lot of people off but that is
not what gets everyone off like there is
something for everybody and I just
wanted to represent a fat sexual person
for people who you know are viewing and
thinking damn I don't see myself
reflected in the porn I watched I don't
feel sexy because I'm overweight
whatever and just seeing me on there
could empower them to feel sexy and
worthy
yeah so representation for me is really
important and I just feel like if
someone sees someone that looks like
them they feel like okay I can't be sexy
I can wear lingerie I can [__] my person
with the lights on and also for people
who are attracted to larger bodies who
may have feel it may feel shame around
it or you know their friends tease them
or whatever if they see that also
reflected in sexual media then they
could hopefully not have shame around
and be out and proud about loving fat
people my dad passed away before I
started doing this and my mom she's
still around she's we're super close and
she she says I'm an adult she says
you're an adult you make your own
choices so I don't know if she loves it
or I don't know if she hates it but I
guess she's indifferent she just you
know and I think it's good you know just
let him in at all yeah yeah and she has
seen how this industry has impacted my
life in lots of positive ways yeah yeah
so in terms of my longevity in this
industry I've been very privileged
because I entered with my husband all of
our friends were like already in the
industry so I I came in in a really
supported area not really someone who
doesn't know anything doesn't have
anyone to help them out and guide them
so I was able to make informed decisions
from the beginning and I was able to for
a long time this wasn't my main source
of income so I was able to have the
privilege again to
say no to certain projects that I didn't
feel we're going to be fun or good for
me and my legacy so and also taking my
time and just having a clear goal on why
I want to do this I think is why I've
been able to do this for so long
they're great yes next level yeah I met
with them I signed with him earlier this
year and from our first meeting I was
just like wow these these people like
really care and they right away they
said it's your body it's your choice and
I didn't because I had heard horror
stories about other agencies that they
pressure you and you can't say no to a
job and I was a little bit apprehensive
approaching an agency because of these
stories I had heard but next level was
not like that they're just like you
choose will offer you a job you can
decline it yeah and they've been in the
industry forever both of them
the main people there so I trust them so
I prefer fat fat girl and and preference
over large yeah but I find that some
people can't say that like they have
like this block around saying that just
because it had that word has said it's
so charged and has such a negative
connotation for most people but that's
how I identify do you find that that
you're being required to do more extreme
things no I think just my knee is bbw
which means big beautiful women that
term is kind of evolving now some people
don't like that term so some people say
plus-sized I like instead of fat because
I know that some people don't like that
word voluptuous is a word that I like
yeah so I don't feel like I that is my
niche and my specialty is just like
representation I have so much fun when I
shoot I think that comes across but I
don't have to glue to like extreme
gaping anal like all this stuff yeah I
don't have to do that although if I
loved it I would love doing it because
you're
that girl you kind of have created your
own little world that doesn't need to be
pushed
yeah empowerment I I guess I don't
really have any and I wish I did because
you know it would be it would be great
to tell you right here but I don't I
mean I guess the craziest thing is that
like how normal we are like off-camera
I feel I feel like we're normal on
camera but it's not something that
everyone would want to do but I think
the craziest thing is just how like
business-minded we are and how genuine
we are for the most part I found the
most sincere like long-lasting
friendships through people I've met
through this industry as opposed to like
my day job that I used to have and all
that stuff I think that there's this
bond that we all have with each other
just because we have shared experiences
and yeah not everyone can do this and
because the industry has evolved so much
we need each other a lot more now for
performing and support and information
and help so yeah I think that was the
most extreme thing is how like not crazy
yeah I'm okay
I'm married so he used to perform also
so he has a he has an understanding of
everything that's involved
oh sit again please okay my future goals
just include growing continuing to grow
in this industry beyond this industry as
an individual I would like to become
better at being behind the camera I feel
like that's where I need some work but
it's just it feels like a natural
progression for me to move to behind the
camera and stay in front of the camera I
just want to keep learning and that's
what's something I try to do from each
shoot just try to learn something each
time about myself about performing about
anything
and just be so comfortable with it yeah
thank you thank you Mark yeah thanks